Hey, are you going to go in the back yard or front yard?
He's coming.
In the back yard?
No.
Okay.
Do you want me to open the door?
Yeah, sure.
He's not coming in.
They're not coming in.
He's still by his car?
Yeah, and he can really stall.
All right.
Someone, video.
It's rolling, guys.
Surprise.
Go a little shot.
Surprise and then say happy birthday.
Should I do it all right?
Yeah.
Surprise then happy birthday.
No, shouts.
Surprise.
Pisces.
volcano.
Pisces.volcano.
Um in between you and me.
We use pass the recoиль technology because we're calling in.
So we take the test.
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you, happy birthday dear Ricky, happy birthday
to you, happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you.